[Music]
well it is an absolutely gorgeous day
here in alaska and i'm gonna try and
catch some hooligan and hooligan are the
first fish of the year
everything's very seasonal here in
alaska and these hooligans come in from
the ocean into the rivers and they're
the very first fish to do that so we're
gonna take these hooligan and use them
as bait for a big camping fishing trip
i've got planned this week
welcome to tourniquet arm one of the
most extreme tides in the world here
they get a 32 foot tide
over that way is the pacific ocean the
gulf of alaska and cook inlet it comes
in here to turn again arm
and there's a series of glacial rivers
up that way that the hooligan are
heading towards
that's a hooligan right there
there's one
hello
look at this
yeah that's more than enough right there
there's a guy just upstream of me that's
doing pretty good i'll go over and chat
with him real quick
oh look at that
nice nice little hole right here yeah it
is
oh my goodness so when we uh
we're smoking at home
i got a big family at home
we've been eating these
thousands of years yeah
awesome we make oil out of them oh yeah
yeah you put them in cookers uh cook
them down for several days and skip it
right off the top what do you use using
for just cooking cooking preserving food
kind of like seal oil kind of like this
all right now that i got bait i'm gonna
pick up my son jacob and we're gonna go
camping and fishing for three days
ready to do some fishing
yes i am
excellent
ready
okay
all right
here we are it's just me and jake
captaining our own boat me and jake have
rented this boat for three days and
we're gonna be camping on this boat and
we're gonna be fishing for rock fish and
halibut and dropping shrimp pots and of
course we're gonna have some awesome
fish to cook up too but first things
first we got about an hour jog through
some of the most gorgeous landscape in
north america
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right i've been driving along for
about an hour and i found a spot with an
underwater cliff at about 400 feet and
it looks like a good spot to try for
some shrimp so we're going to drop some
shrimp pots
we got these little big cages i'm gonna
fill them up with chopped up hooligan
shrimp pellets and herring oil
got some of our fresh hooligans
we're gonna go head out deeper and see
if we can find some fish in over a
thousand feet of water
we're going to be fishing between 500 to
1500 feet of water
using two to four pound lead so you
can't do it by hand it's just
brutal to try to reel that up and
checking your baits and things like that
just become a massive chore unless
you've got electric rails
got a two pound lead weight here
you see basically i just got two hooks
with these little blinking lights on
them as soon as they get wet they
activate and they'll attract fish deep
down in the darkness
got two nice chunks of squid on our
hooks
and drop this down
right now we're in about 450 feet of
water it's gonna take about a minute for
that two pound lead to get all the way
to the bottom
there we go
all right let's go get another run out
oh yeah he's on there okay watch this
jake you ready
[Music]
isn't that cool
it's gonna take a couple minutes to reel
this thing up
all right we've done about a minute and
a half and we just got halfway up
all right jake you wanna you wanna reel
it
here come here
oh you got that
oh that's heavy
oh i could see something
look at that how do you get the baby
hell of it
oh
look at that
little baby chicken hell of it you want
to keep them or send them back
all right
we've been fishing about five minutes
and we already caught a halibut well
we've been drifting around for about an
hour since we caught that little halibut
and not much has happened since then so
we're gonna pick up and try another spot
jake do you want to try reeling up the
rods
yeah okay go reel up your rod
this way over that way like this see
this
just watch your fingers don't let your
fingers get caught in them
there's 650 feet of line out here
it's going to take a while to pull those
up
oh look at this
oh there's a little baby fish on here
that is a
yeah that's a dusky rock fish
a little tiny one but he's a tasty fish
i'll put him in the ice box
first mate jake get in your seat
all right is this fun jake yes yeah it
is
all right guys we went a little deeper
we're in about a thousand feet of water
okay bombs away
989 feet
oh that looked like a fish jake
yeah that's a bite right there that was
a bite go check it buddy
yeah you know how
[Music]
wow
look at you look how much yours is that
i think you might have something on
there jake
[Music]
all right
oh
oh
[Music]
oh we got a mess that's what we got
all right the shrimp pot's been in the
water for about three hours now we're
just gonna check it and see if there's
anything in it if there is we're gonna
throw it back and let it sit overnight
if not
go try another spot
[Music]
all right
there we go there's two
oh
oh
oh
wow wow
look at those beautiful prawns
all right
oh look at that that is cool well i mean
that's not the most amazing pull ever
but that's not bad for just three hours
i think we need to just go put our pots
back and let it sit overnight and we'll
get a bunch of these tomorrow what do
you think jake
all right we're going to let that sit
all night long
should we start getting ready for bed
yes this is house
so josh
that's how soldiers get ready for bed
that's right yes so you're all soldier
jammies
got all camo'ed up well it's getting
late so we're gonna find a spot close to
our shrimp pots where we can aim her up
for the night and uh we're just gonna
fish and cook and take it easy and
just have a good night here on the boat
oh yeah hold on i gotta drop the anchor
all right guys well since we're anchored
up i'm gonna make a little chum bag and
we're gonna chum this spot up and fish
while we cook and camp and it'll be real
nice
and we want you and soaks definitely
like
that
yeah we've got like a four pound lead
and a snagging hook
the snagging hooks got the ziploc bag
through the tough part
on the bottom
reel up
there you go it just tears a hole all
the chum goes out the garbage comes back
up
oh that's a big carrying of water
oh are you going to set something on
fire
well
what's his channel
oh i think i got a fish on here
[Music]
you don't take this rod i just gotta
bite you
oh look at this
oh
yes
a rock fish
that's a quillback rock fish that is a
delicious fish not a huge one but
definitely a
keeper oh yeah we got one
look at this
oh nice
yeah it's a yellow white rock fish
whoa another tasty fish the spots turned
out to be pretty good for the rock fish
cocktail sauce
those shrimp are good aren't they
oh that cocktail sauce hit this spot too
those are tasty shrimp
i hope we catch a whole bunch more of
those
[Music]
rice pudding it looks good it is so good
you like it
oh hey there's this shrimp
all right we're gonna keep you warm
tonight
there you go
we're gonna keep you warm
all right let's get you to bed
here's your blankie
you need to get the bed in there okay
oh i am embarrassed to say it is 11
o'clock and jacob is still up we
we have got to get that little boy to
sleep and i have got to get some rest
too because we have a full day of
fishing tomorrow i will see you guys in
the morning
good morning
sleep good jake
well it is gorgeous out here
oh look at this
these are a tasty fish but you're only
allowed one per day so i think i'm gonna
go ahead and send him back he's in
pretty good shape i'm gonna go ahead and
use this deep releaser let me go and
hook the fish's mouth like this
when you pull a fish up for more than
about 60 70 feet he gets what's called
barotrauma where his air bladder expands
from coming up from the deep flasher and
it and it makes so they can't swim down
you just take it down there
shake them off reel it up
oh
oh man what a haul
look at all the sea lice
there we go
nice octopus
specific octopus that's a small one but
they are tasty
me and jake got to catch and cook some
of those just a few weeks ago i'm
looking forward to doing that again
oh yeah
look at that little sea urchin
oh look at all the lies
good morning jacob
good morning
all right we're gonna try something a
little different we're gonna fish a
little bit shallower we're in just 200
feet here we're gonna see if we can't
pick up some rock fish but jigging
there we go got a fish
look at that giant sculpin right there
[Music]
look at that
nice
you know the wind and the waves have
picked up just a little bit i don't like
it i think i'm gonna go find another
spot ready go for a drive jake
all right we're gonna just try a quick
drop here
[Music]
oh 330 feet to go
[Music]
check it out it's a yellow-eyed rock
fish
oh you got one jake
oh no it's a kelp gree league
you want to throw it back
here
bam just got another one right away
oh nice
oh a dusky rock fish
[Music]
oh another yellow eye
[Music]
oh
look at that
look at that jake
wearing them thick here
there you go jake
[Music]
yeah yes oh another yellow eye
is it is it a dusky or is it a quail
back i think it's a dusky
oh it's a dusky rock fish perfect
there we go a dusky
it's a little golden eye
man this has been a nice little honey
hole we probably pulled 12 rock fish out
of here so i'm gonna pull up and just
move down this coast and try a few more
spots and see if we can get into some
dusty rock fish or maybe some lean cod
and maybe some halibut
we got a couple bites on this
sir oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah go
hold on
what do you think it is what do you
think it is
oh
look at that monster what is that oh
look at this a massive yellow eye
oh yeah
this is what we've caught before look at
that that is a big one look at it look
at the size of him
i think we're gonna keep this one
check it out we're in the middle of
prince william sound the gulf of alaska
is just right over there and it is just
quiet and calm as glass out here look at
look at this water
oh look at that
okay i know some of you guys may think
these electric reels are cheating i love
them i'm absolutely spoiled i may never
go back
this is so nice
oh
yes
look at that beauty
you can see coming up from the depth
absolutely trashes the fish makes their
eyeballs pop out see his liver his air
bladder will come out
but luckily that one is super tasty
so uh he ain't going back
oh my goodness these things make amazing
fish tacos
oh i am i am pleased
you know these electric reels just let
me fish spots i would never fish
otherwise cranking up four pounds of
lead over 600 feet is miserable stuff
the electric reels let you get to spots
that no one else is really touching
yeah there it is
there we go
[Music]
look at that
oh we got we got two shrimp
that was pretty pitiful
look at this see
it's got a little creature in it i'm
gonna put fresh bait in all of these and
uh we're gonna try a different spot
all right buddy
you doing well down there you staying
warm down there yes good
the heater comes out under the table and
so that's where i find jacob
let's get some dinner going here i want
to eat some shrimp
these shrimp are just massive
oh they're so delicious
[Music]
it's chocolate milk
oh yes
that's soldier chocolate milk
look at the size of these shrimp these
things are huge
[Music]
[Music]
oh those hooligan made great bait i'm
almost out of all the hooligan i caught
oh look at this
a nice cool back rock fish one two three
because the rockfish kind of inflate
like balloons when you bring them up
from the depth you have to use these
deep water releasers to get them back
down once they get down to depth they go
back to their normal size and buoyancy
and they can swim away
so basically you just put this through
their bottom lip send them down when
they get to the bottom you shake the
fish off the hook
bring the hook back up all right
okay hop in there all right lay down
buddy
you're down it's bedtime
well it's been a wonderful day but it's
late and i've got to get to bed i'll see
you guys in the morning
[Music]
we we lucked out with the weather on
this trip i think this calls for a
little more fishing
um yeah let's do that i'm gonna go pull
anchor
all right first mate jacob shall we go
find a fishing spot
let's do it
we're in a little bit shallower water
it's only about 500 feet here so i'm
gonna use my weighted jig with a
hooligan head on it
see how this goes hey check it out it's
the kennecott that's the ferry that goes
from washington state to whittier alaska
me and jacob spent five days on that
ship it was part of our longest road
trip in the united states video where we
drove from key west florida to dead
horse alaska it was a good time jacob
yes it was that was a fun trip
oh what do we got
oh
nice dusky rock fish on the hooligan
oh got another
one you go another little dusky
oh
another dusky
dang we're into him now
hey jake i got a big fish
yeah yeah you're a fighter too
there you go jake that's your that's
your rockfish
that's a beauty
well guys this has been fun
but we're out of time we gotta go back
and check those shrimp pots and i gotta
get things all cleaned up
let's go pull a shrimp pot
all right
jake here put them in there
okay you fill up that
you don't need any help all right all
right you go get them jake
heidi
picked up about 25 30 shrimp that'll be
very nice for dinner tonight
[Music]
huh we made it
[Music]
all right guys we're back at the house
and it's time to cook up some seafood
check this out it's so fresh it's still
moving
[Music]
i'm serving the fish with this homemade
ginger black bean sauce that i made just
keep a big jar of it
all right guys you ready for dinner
this is a ginger black bean garlic sauce
for
the sheriff was the good part wasn't it
the shrimp was sure was really good
well listen guys that was a fun trip
hopefully you enjoyed this video as much
as we enjoyed catching those fish if you
guys want to see more videos from the
outdoor boys youtube channel make sure
to click subscribe we put out new videos
every saturday morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]